[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
hoy desde Asunción Paraguay donde
estamos con el presidente Mario abdo
señor presidente un placer saludarle
Muchísimas gracias por concedernos esta
entrevista exclusiva señor presidente un
gusto Valeria para mí estamos realmente
muy agradecidos que nos acompañen en
este momento Bueno usted en agosto deja
la presidencia con un resultado
importante Paraguay es el país que más
crece de la región y eso a pesar de una
pandemia de unas inundaciones de una
sequía y de otros problemas que tuvo que
enfrentar en su mandato Cuál ha sido el
secreto de este éxito
nosotros nos hemos concentrado
en enfrentar y en construir programas de
contingencia y hemos podido prever las
consecuencias y construir políticas
públicas que nos permitan enfrentar con
éxito las diferentes dificultades que
tuvimos en este periodo de cinco años
ante el primer caso de covid positivo
tomamos las medidas más drásticas pero
permitimos algunos sectores de la
economía seguir funcionando tal
respetando los protocolos sanitarios en
el año 2020 donde la pandemia impacta a
todas las economías del mundo la región
cae un promedio de 7,4% de su producto
interno bruto la región Paraguay
solamente cae 0,8% fuimos los primeros
en cerrar También fuimos los primeros en
ir progresivamente abriendo y el año
2021 de vuelta no fuimos hacia un
crecimiento creo que llegamos creo que
al tres coma nueve por ciento o sea el
2021 ya se sintió un proceso de
recuperación post pandemia eso fue en
términos de el año duro de la pandemia y
en general nosotros apostamos
a 5g prioritario 1 fortalecer la
institucionalidad para enviar un mensaje
a la comunidad
nacional e internacional que Paraguay
tiene condiciones
muy interesantes para la inversión
en nuestro gobierno tenemos la mayor
inversión extranjera de la historia del
Paraguay a pesar de la pandemia Y eso
creo que fue gracias a unas medidas que
tomamos primero
avanzar hacia una renovación del poder
judicial
segundo hemos hecho una gran apuesta a
obras de infraestructura y de
conectividad teniendo en cuenta que
Paraguay es un país sin litoral sin
acceso directo al mar hemos construido
más carreteras que en los últimos 30
años una ruta que estamos construyendo
es la ruta de Dios oceánica que va a
permitir la Paraguay ser la unión
Imagínese de ser un país mediterráneo
por por el corazón del Chaco paraguayo
va a pasar la conexión del Océano
Atlántico con el océano Pacífico y gran
parte de la producción de la región que
hoy sale por el Océano Atlántico y tiene
que subir y cruzar por el canal de
Panamá va a cruzar por el Chaco
paraguayo y va a llegar al mercado del
Pacífico también Paraguay es el cuarto
exportador de soja del mundo El noveno
de carne pero ahora tenemos por primera
vez nuestra historia en nuestra matriz
productiva tenemos exportación de
manufactura industrializada del mismo
volumen que manufactura de granos por
ejemplo o de carne o de grano en estado
natural eso significa que nuestra matriz
productiva sea diversificado y se ha
fortalecido y eso demostró también la
resiliencia en los momentos de crisis
creo que todo eso de A poco está
generando una visibilidad de Paraguay y
un gran interés que nos permitió y que
nos permite y según este el Banco
Mundial la perspectiva la expectativa es
que Paraguay sea la economía que más va
a crecer en el año 2023 en estos cinco
años se quedó algo en el tintero cosas
que le hubiese gustado hacer pero que no
dio tiempo
mucho A lo mejor algo que nosotros
teníamos pendiente y era un objetivo de
nuestra gestión de gobierno era
visibilizarle más a Paraguay ante el
mundo yo creo que mucha gente no conoce
Paraguay bueno y teníamos una agenda
importante intensa pero esa agenda fue
obviamente interrumpida consecuencia de
dos años que tuvimos que darle todo
nuestro énfasis Nuestro esfuerzo nuestra
nuestra creatividad y nuestro tiempo a
enfrentar las consecuencias de la
pandemia verdad Tal vez usted sea el
único presidente de Paraguay que no ha
coqueteado con la idea de una reelección
ahora que está a punto de dejar el cargo
cree que habría que cambiar la
Constitución para poder permitir la
reelección porque Paraguay es una
excepción en ese sentido muchos países
permiten la reelección creo
absolutamente que hay que revisar
nuestra Constitución la Constitución que
tenemos se hizo en el año 92
y creo que en todos estos años hemos
aprendido mucho creo que es momento para
empezar a debatir sobre una reforma
constitucional y dentro de esa de ese
debate que tienen que haber muchas otras
cosas
incorporadas dentro de ese debate la
figura de la reelección presidencial
creo que es una figura necesaria A lo
mejor de manera alternada para seguir
profundizando nuestra conciencia
democrática la importancia por lo menos
de la alternancia de la persona en el
poder la administración de la burocracia
pública es una una carrera constante
contra la burocracia y muchas veces un
periodo presidencial es insuficiente
pero yo me comprometí con mi pueblo
cuando me candidatea presidente de la
república que no iba a ser ningún
intento de modificar la Constitución En
beneficio de mi persona y bueno y cumplí
ese compromiso que hice y estoy muy
satisfecho de poder salir porque creo
que eso también es un legado importante
el cumplimiento compromisos reconstruir
la confianza con la ciudadanía a través
del cumplimiento de los compromisos
verdad Y creo que ese fue un hecho
importante que fortalece y que nos da
autoridad para avanzar hacia un diálogo
bueno Quién va a ganar el 30 de abril la
democracia paraguaya que gane que se
respete la voluntad popular lo más
importante es que el proceso democrático
las elecciones sea una muestra más de la
responsabilidad y del compromiso cívico
de una sociedad que va madurando como la
nuestra que el mundo pueda ver en
Paraguay unas elecciones limpias
transparentes tal vez apasionadas
necesarias como en todas las democracias
del mundo pero que apostemos a el
respeto a la institucionalidad yo tengo
el compromiso de invitar al que gane las
elecciones para hacer una un proceso de
transición ordenado para que el próximo
gobierno
pueda llevar adelante las políticas
públicas que así considera el presidente
pero que tenga toda la información y
todo el respaldo del gobierno saliente
en las últimas semanas ha ganado fuerza
un nuevo candidato Payo cubas que parece
un candidato antisistema no y le
pregunto si usted cree que él tendría
posibilidad de canalizar el descontento
de una parte de la población lo pregunto
porque en Brasil cuando Yair bolsonaro
presentó a su candidatura muchas
personas no se lo tomaron en serio y
acabó ganando no yo creo que
definitivamente
el paraguayo Cuba va a ser una una buena
elección de hecho va a ser tal vez la
sorpresa sin que eso signifique que
estoy adelantando un resultado Pero la
sorpresa en el sentido de que
irrumpió como un modelo como un proyecto
que
demuestra que hay una gran deuda de la
clase política para con la sociedad
bueno y Ahí se refleja la popularidad y
la aceptación de su proyecto político
primero creo que es saludable que la
sociedad tenga un espacio donde pueda
verse representada
independientemente a
las diferencias que podamos tener con
sus propuestas
Pero creo que es un espacio donde la
ciudadanía también
manifiesta un reclamo a la clase
política tradicional tal vez o al
funcionamiento de su democracia y
tenemos que tomar como un mensaje claro
y bueno eso tiene que ser también una
corresponsabilidad de todos de atender a
ese segmento de nuestra sociedad que
nos está enviando un mensaje verdad Don
que quiere una mejor calidad de
democracia que quiere cambios la
democracia señor presidente me gustaría
preguntarle como ve usted el futuro del
partido Colorado lo pregunto porque el
presidente del partido Colorado Horacio
cartes ha sido declarado
significativamente corrupto por la
embajada de los Estados Unidos hay unas
económicas e internacionalmente se ve
con cierta preocupación esta sombra del
Señor cartes sobre la política nacional
y nacionalmente las calles yo también
escucho muchos comentarios negativos En
ese sentido Entonces cómo usted ve esta
situación
y va a ser una gran tarea habrá
realmente Una pregunta compleja porque
la reconstrucción
del coloradismo lo hace una tarea
compleja
lo que está viviendo el partido yo no
puedo eludir lo que a su pregunta verdad
en un momento muy duro porque el espacio
de la política tiene que ser un espacio
que genere Esperanza construir una
sociedad con valores con los valores de
la integridad de la moral política de la
ética y cuando está
tan este comprometida verdad con con
dudosa reputación de quienes están al
frente de la conducción política
se distorsiona un poco la función de un
partido político pero yo tengo esperanza
independientemente a la persona reitero
no voy a aludir la pregunta es un
momento trágico que vivió el coloradismo
ante esta situación
yo creo que en su momento tiene que
haber un debate fuerte al interior del
partido una vez que culmine el proceso
electoral nosotros jugamos a marcar una
diferencia y vamos a proponer un
coloradismo donde el centro de Nuestra
fuerza y de nuestra corriente de
pensamiento o sea justamente recuperar
un partido Colorado con credibilidad y
que sea un partido que pueda marcar una
diferencia a la actual conducción del
partido Colorado
datos de la coordinadora de derechos
humanos de Paraguay laco de uppi
muestran que el crimen organizado ha
premiado varios estamentos del Estado
paraguayo incluidos los partidos
políticos usted como presidente se va
con la conciencia tranquila de haber
luchado todo lo que podía o podía haber
hecho más y como siempre digo Siempre
tal vez pudimos haber hecho más pero
en nuestro gobierno creo que hemos
tenido los resultados definitivamente
hemos tenido los resultados más
importantes contra el crimen organizado
y yo coincido con la visión de codeupi y
Nosotros hemos denunciado eso en campaña
y desde la gestión de gobierno hemos
hecho los operativos más grandes en
contra del crimen organizado donde hubo
vinculación política hay diputados que
fueron puestos a disposición de la
justicia hemos hecho operativos donde
por primera vez la historia del Paraguay
no solamente cayó aquel que trafica
droga o que cultiva marihuana si no
vemos gran parte del patrimonio del
crimen organizado tuvo puesto a la
sociedad hay un operativo que lleva el
nombre de ultranza que fue el operativo
más grande donde hemos incautado más de
200 a millones de dólares de patrimonio
del crimen del crimen organizado y hemos
puesto al servicio de la sociedad y
muchos que se creían Intocables también
en nuestro gobierno dieron que no son
Intocables el crimen organizado no tiene
fronteras usted ha de saber hace poco a
un fiscal paraguayo se le ha asesinado
en Cartagena Colombia verdad O sea ahí
demuestra
como una un fiscal paraguayo el crimen
organizado con sus brazos largos pudo
asesinarlo en otro país a consecuencia
de las medidas que toma en Paraguay y
ahí se demuestra claramente
qué es lo que más eficientemente se ha
globalizado en el mundo es el crimen
organizado y tenemos que trabajar con
cooperación y para tener cooperación
Tenemos que tener autoridad verdad
porque quién va a creer en un gobierno
que de alguna manera dice querer luchar
contra el crimen organizado y por otro
lado es complaciente con el crimen
organizado en su país o esto señor
presidente cuando usted presentó su
candidatura una parte de la oposición
paraguaya y de la prensa destacó la
historia de su familia el hecho de que
su padre había sido un colaborador de
streesner usted ha sentido a principio
de su mandato este peso del pasado al
inicio de mi carrera política fue un
prejuicio que fue parte de
de los desafíos en mi carrera política
pero yo antes de ser presidente fui
senador
también Creo que juntos con la oposición
mientras que yo fui senador
tuvimos posiciones muy claras en defensa
del Estado de derecho en defensa de la
Democracia entonces con mi con mi acto
creo que eso se ha diluido en mi carrera
política hoy ya como senador y como
presidente
no creo que nadie pueda decir que es un
presidente que utilizó el poder con
fines
de perseguir a adversario político al
revés ni siquiera casi interferían otro
poder del Estado hasta se me cuestionaba
porque latinoamérica tiene una cultura
muy paternalista donde de repente la
gente Espera que el presidente controle
el congreso controle la justicia de
repente te dicen por qué presidente este
no está preso no porque el presidente no
le puede meter preso a nadie eso tiene
es una tarea de la fiscalía del sistema
de Justicia señor presidente Muchísimas
gracias por esta entrevista en exclusiva
France 24 y gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos hasta aquí les invitamos a
que sigan nuestra programación en France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]